we'll talk to Barry Trammell he covers
the Oklahoma City Thunder for the
Oklahoma and he'll join us coming up
he's got a weird relationship with
Russell Westbrook you know you might
have witnessed these press conferences
where he'll be on with after the game
with Russell Westbrook and he asked the
first question normally and Russell
Westbrook always says next question no
matter what Barry Trammell asked Russell
Westbrook always says next question and
watching on NBA TV sometimes I just tune
in for the first question because
Westbrook doesn't even look up he
doesn't even acknowledge Barry Trammell
the columnist for the Oklahoma and Barry
joins us now Barry how are you today
alright ok explain the next question
thing when it first started and where
you are now with your relationship with
Russell Westbrook
oh I don't you know I don't maybe it
started in January this latest rendition
started in January he didn't like a
question I asked and he's been hitting
me was next question ever since but it
goes back three or four years yeah when
he said he didn't like me he was he was
sort of stonewalling all the media and I
said it is Russ is something wrong and
he said no why I said well you're not
answering anybody's question he said I
just don't like you so I took that as I
sort of took that as an encouragement
sign because at the time it was six or
seven years and two Russ's career and it
was the first time he'd ever
acknowledged that he knew who I was so I
I took that as a positive sign so I
don't know I think Russ just likes to be
at war with the media and he sort of
singled me out as sort of the face of
yeah but Barry you guys are you guys are
media friendly group there I think like
in theory right you guys are
we don't really have Woodward or
Bernstein energy yeah it's not this is
not not a bunch of Bulldogs and and
there's no it's not it's not there's
nothing bad to write about the Thunder
story I mean they haven't won the title
but outside of that it's a fabulous
story I mean they've been in town 11
years and had 10 good years in the one
year they weren't any good was the first
year they were here and everybody loved
them anyway so yeah I think Russ just
likes to invent enemies he does it on
the court you see that all the time hmm
with people like JJ Barea and Damian
Lillard and you know dozen other guys
and I think he does the same thing with
in the media finish this sentence if the
Thunder lose tonight well the season is
over and there will be pressure for
significant change
what's that Thunder is not reactionary
so I would be surprised if there was
significant change and significant
change means Sam Presti Billy Donovan
Russell Westbrook Paul George that's the
four primaries and I don't you know I
don't think you're going to see any of
those four do any changing so there are
a lot of questions about the future but
the truth is the whatever whatever
changes are made will probably be fairly
minor but I also look at this situation
and I'm wondering what Paul George sees
with his team and Russell Westbrook that
Kevin Durant was tired of seeing with
this team in Russell Westbrook is that
fair to put those two in the same
situation here well it is it's a
wonderful question because you know
Durant I think you're right Durant on
whatever level for whatever reason was
tired of the of the situation and maybe
he wasn't tired of anything in
particular maybe just wanted to change
but George sort of embraced you know he
jumped on board and embraced playing
with Westbrook and they've been good
together I mean George was before he
hurt his shoulder and fed
he was an MVP candidate yeah but it is a
good question because it's it's not
working particularly well compared to
the standard that they want which is
contend for title buddy you know he
signed on for at least three years with
an option for fourth so that's to me
that was a that was an endorsement of
Westbrook and something that we have to
remember when we talk about how
difficult it might be to play with
Westbrook because George found it not
just doable but enjoyable so it's that's
an intriguing element to this and this
this season has has been a
disappointment you know they were they
were right on the heels of the Nuggets
and the Warriors that they all start
breaking and then they needed a Paul
George miracle shot to avoid the eighth
seed in the last week of the season so
it's been a disappointment this series
has been a disappointment and now
they've got they've got to see where
they go from here play yeah therapist
here psychiatrist here with Kevin Durant
from afar these cryptic answers
assertive his body language here you you
witnessed this first and maybe you
didn't know that he was going to leave
but is there similar body language
cryptic comments that you can go back to
Oklahoma City that you're hearing and
seeing now with Golden State on what his
future might be no invasion of the body
snatchers has occurred the Kevin Durant
we see out in Oakland there's nothing
like the Durant we saw in Oklahoma City
I don't know which is the real one you
know it maybe this is the real Durant
maybe I don't know but I can tell you
this what the way he's acting he acts
unhappy you know how he acts to me but
if the warrior fans want to feel better
he acted really happy in Oklahoma City
even down to the last you know the last
month of the of his stay here and then
he left
so maybe acting unhappy means he'll stay
I don't know
we tend to think he's going to leave
Oakland's most people around the league
think he's going to leave Oakland he
seems like a guy that's still sort of
searching for himself you know that's
the one thing he said about Russell
Westbrook he's not really in search of
himself he sort of has he settled on
Plymouth Rock so you know we think
Durant will leave but who knows we
thought he was going to stay three years
ago do you automatically get first
question at every press conference with
the Thunder with Russell Westbrook oh
yeah since January it's three months
three straight months and the question
there really the only intrigue is am I
going to ask a follow-up and if I've got
a legit follow-up I'll ask it if I don't
I won't press the issue because you know
Russell just likes to control stuff
that's really what it is you can see
that in the way plays the way he sort of
conducts himself around the team and he
gets frustrated I think when he thinks
he can't control the media a couple of
times when I've hit him with a follow up
question he'll call for the for the
media relations guy he'll say you know
what do you want to do what do you want
to do he's he doesn't like things to get
out of control so it's an unfortunate
situation I'm hoping that the offseason
sort of settles it down and we can sort
of start over and and go where go
nowhere again next year but at least it
be a fresh start
Barry thank you for answering my
questions you bet
I appreciate it that's a Barry Trammell
sports columnist for the Oklahoma for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR Live or download the Dan
Patrick show app